the Clean Air Act required all new cars
to be equipped with catalytic converters
to combat air pollution the first date
to do this was California which led
Texans to say things like I hate
California in the ocean not everyone was
happy about it six years later one
particular Texan saw an opportunity to
get rich quick oh man I'm gonna get rich
quick I just got my ticket out of here
adios I'm serious this thing is full of
tips on how to make a fortune only cost
me a dollar is one of the tips make a
crappy news letter and charge idiots a
dollar for it
no but not a bad idea
listen to this raise bees and sell the
honey for profit do it I'm living with
Nemo sell bluhdorn on Dino organs mmm
give me your brain you're not using I
think that's the only time I've ever
heard you laugh that's the only time
you've ever been funny whoa Platinum can
be extracted from ordinary roadside
gravel no it can't actually it can
catalytic converters contain Platinum
micro particles of that Platinum are
expelled me exhaust and are mixed in
with the gravel see this thing's a gold
mine it would be more apt to call it a
platinum line
I laughed at your joke hey what you
doing playing a historically accurate
game called the Oregon Trail that sounds
boring hardly my wagon broke an axle and
my wife died of dysentery what can you
pause it for sec
it does seem rude to push on to Oregon
while my daughter Mabel is mourning the
loss of her mother what can I do for you
remember when we were talking that
platinum and gravel do you know how to
get it out it's not a complicated
principle I could probably do it with my
professor proton chemistry set okay and
an oven that reaches 2,000 degrees Goods
Arvinder that no but I read you can
build one out of a garbage can and a
leaf blower cool let's mine some
platinum no thank you I don't care about
money
but you care about science right of
course so I offer you the chance to do
an experiment you'd rather play a video
game
what would professor proton think he'd
be disappointed so what do you say I say
we collect gravel there you go in case
you're worried Mable and I did finally
make it to Oregon where I remarried and
live to the ripe old age of 41
[Music]